[Music]
i read and watched videos for many
people who claim they saw aliens or ufos
here on planet earth
[Music]
and some of these people say that they
have captured it on camera
they know the precise orbital an
invisible stone and so where did the
information come from that's the serious
mystery i can't tell you how
electrifying it was people have
increasingly over time lost their
imagination
i've seen plans in the archives there is
some reality there to the
experimentation
that's why i'll keep asking and
searching
crashed into one of the towers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the nazis may have been shooting rockets
up you have to be open-minded there is a
mystery i think that the ancient
egyptians were pretty amazing
do aliens exist
and have they been visiting the earth
since ancient times
i was born in egypt at the crossroads
between two cultures the arab muslim
culture and the ancient egyptian history
since i was young i am fascinated by the
ancient egyptian monuments and their
magnificent size
how did they manage to build such
gigantic structures
growing up i learned that there are many
theories which try to answer this
question
but the theory which attracted me when i
was younger is that it was constructed
by the help of aliens from outer space
then all the questions started
my family are all engineers and doctors
i chose to study economics but at the
same time i joined the theater and i
became impressed by the classics and
mythology
and the history of the ancient world
on one side i value science and on the
other side i have a passion for culture
and stories
i was raised to use my brain and to be
logical and ask questions
many questions about everything and when
i get the answer i find myself coming
back with more questions
like a mathematical exercise or an
experiment in physics
it is the same for mysteries
they're all questions
and one has to look for answers
what is the relation between aliens and
ancient cultures
in my search for an answer to this
question i found a book called chariots
of the gods
written in the sixties by eric
vandanaken who deciphers in it the
drawings and legends of ancient cultures
his explanation claims that the gods in
some of the ancient drawings are
essentially aliens who used to and still
do come to visit the earth and that
those aliens are the ones who taught
humanity how to build civilization and
to build gigantic structures such as the
pyramid
i found this explanation in another book
called the serious mystery by the
american writer robert temple
which talks about the dogon tribe in
mali especially about their advanced and
precise astrophysical knowledge about a
star that is invisible to the naked eye
from a tribe in africa in mali the dogon
it cannot be chance that they know the
precise orbital period of an invisible
star
they draw pictures of the orbit and they
know the orbital period and so where did
the information come from that's the
serious mystery now if you ask the dog
where it came from they say that their
ancestors were given this information by
visitors from the system of the star
sirius
[Music]
in my search for the truth behind the
ancient astronaut theory i found lynn
picknit who has a completely different
point of view
lynn picknet is a writer and researcher
in modern mysteries whose extensive work
tends to disagree with the ancient alien
theories of eric von daniken and robert
temple
hi lynn
thank you for making the time
pleasure i wanted to talk to you about
uh ancient astronauts when did you first
hear about that um i can remember 1968 i
was a young woman when eric von
danicum's book chariots of the gods
first came out and it was serialized in
the sunday newspapers where i live well
in in the uk throughout the uk um and i
can't tell you how electrifying
it was but very sadly as the years
progressed
and i and i started to delve into these
sort of subjects you know i just
came to realize that
very few if any of the examples that
vandankin had given
for him to back up his theory actually
held water that they're actually true
there are many books that followed it it
was almost like a trend
the concept became so popular that even
carl sagan famously pondered about this
too
look at this in the long litany of
ancient astronaut pop archaeology
the cases of apparent interest have
perfectly reasonable alternative
explanations
or have been misreported or are simple
pre-verifications
hoaxes
and distortions uncode first of all i
think carl sagan was the most remarkable
person and he was incredibly open-minded
especially for a scientist
but i think he's honorable he's right
okay can you give us an example of a
perfectly reasonable alternative
explanation for example that the various
little artifacts are found in various
places but mainly in south america
which not for all the world is quite
right they look exactly like modern
aircraft with the two wings and the
bullet-like body and the tail but when
you discover that that particular
culture actually um really revered
certain types of insects and certain
types of birds and in fact these were
representations of insects and birds
highly stylized you know but
nevertheless that's what they were what
about robert temple and the doggones the
mystery of series a and serious bees the
stars nobody knows how the dogon learnt
this it is a genuine mystery and it's
very exciting potentially
however one should be perhaps
guarded shall i say about accepting too
much in um temple's book just on face
value
because um some of the things that he
says are actually just simply untrue
okay
any other proof that it wasn't
extraterrestrials that taught us how to
build these magnificent ancient
structures like the pyramids a lot of
people do point to the you know the
burgeoning of a pyramid building across
the world but actually it wasn't
remotely at the same time
um you know there's no longer who would
be interested in an alternative version
of our ancient history and if it wasn't
ancient astronauts then how did our
great ancestors develop their knowledge
to such advanced levels the fact remains
that there is a mystery you know i mean
i am i am open-minded i'm not a skeptic
about this you know you have to be
open-minded there is a mystery
[Music]
during world war ii
several allied pilots reported seeing
flying objects of impossible speeds
it is said that the nazis were very much
into the occult and the paranormal
actually they were not the only ones
investing and researching in these
things
there were others doing it too
eric corlander may have some insight
he has a phd from harvard university
and is a professor in history
specializing in nazi history and nazi's
most obscure interests and developments
hi eric thank you for talking to me i
wanted to discuss with you the nazis and
their possible connection to the ufo
phenomena i'm happy to
to discuss it it seems that the nazis
were very much into the ufos and
coincidentally at the same time
they were developing sophisticated
aircrafts and alternative propulsion
systems i've seen plans in the archives
of you know they were really obsessed
with how do we take down all these
allied
planes coming over so they were thinking
about sophisticated anti-flack
devices the kugelblitz and some other
things
so
there is some
reality there to the experimentation i'm
arguing it just didn't work so
experiments not ufos or aliens and
there are no amazing machines with
superpowers i haven't seen any evidence
for that there was a crash of an
unidentified object in the black forest
in germany sometime during world war ii
and then in 1947 a similar crash
happened in roswell in the united states
supposedly those were weathered weather
balloons right at roswell
um
i certainly don't think it was a ufo
where they experiment with something
beyond weather balloons it's possible i
haven't seen any evidence so could these
crashes in germany and the united states
only a few years apart
be just a transfer of technology rather
than ufos and aliens
we know that some of the german
scientists and some of the american
scientists who worked with them
were interested in these kinds of
alternative propulsion i mean the whole
rocket program was based on the idea
that nazis had come up with
jet propulsion and other technologies
that we hadn't yet
mastered i can see how the public
if they see such objects would easily
believe they are ufos
[Music]
are these arguments accurate scientific
deductions or are they just the work of
fertile imagination maybe there's
another explanation
i'm not saying anyone is wrong i just
must be careful
evidence that something took place is
not a proof of how it happened then you
need to dig deeper
the question keeps buzzing in my head
and sometimes the answer is in the
question itself
its motivations and reasons
why does it have to be that aliens are
the ones who helped the ancient
civilizations
why are we asking this question
i have to talk to salim ikram doctor of
egyptology at the american university in
cairo
hi salima considering your expertise on
ancient cultures i wanted to ask you why
is there an alternative version of our
past our great civilizations people
can't get their head around the fact
that human beings
without all the technology we have today
or even you know say 80 years ago
could actually make something because it
seems to me that people have
increasingly over time
lost their imagination and lost their
faith in human beings
and also though it is true because you
know oh
part of it not everyone but part of it
is oh those brown people or black people
couldn't have possibly done this could
they i mean look at them now
so
it's not exactly ignorance but rather
racism
partially racism and partially
ignorance and also
a desire for the fantastic
there's a there's a definitely a racist
element
but there's also
a lack of faith in all of humankind how
so the increase of interest in aliens
nowadays is because people are
emotionally and spiritually bankrupt and
they also are so
divorced from nature and their own motor
skills that they cannot fathom that
these ancient egyptians with
logs rope and a lot of muscle and
obstinacy managed to create the most
extraordinary and beautiful buildings
ever constructed in the world they did
it by observing nature it wasn't just
you know newton who had the apple fall
in his head the idea that the natural
world can teach you things and they are
natural laws the ancient egyptians died
i see i actually am not against
something amazing i think that the
ancient egyptians were pretty amazing
i'm sorry that i'm such a
non-uh alienist yay to the ancient
egyptians they were the greatest
many civilizations built amazing
structures and accumulated incredible
knowledge
ancient egypt and sumer
are just two among many cultures with a
golden era as part of the history
they each left behind a vast legacy
if it weren't aliens who helped ancient
civilizations build their amazing
structures
then how did our ancestors accomplish so
much
what was their source of knowledge
that is still a question i'd like an
answer for
that's why i'll keep asking and
searching
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you